hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i wanted to talk
about
all of the news and speculation that
came out after i said on the kind of
funny x-cast that a retailer had
told me the prices they had listed in
their systems for the xbox series x
so we'll do that but um in more dramatic
news i do also have
another price leak this time with
pictures from a retailer in the uk
that i will also show but there's other
stuff that i want to say first
so i said on the kind of funny x-cast
which for anyone who doesn't know
is a xbox podcast that goes up on
youtube.com
kind of funny games that a retailer had
messaged me and said that the xbox
series
x price was listed in their systems as
5.99
i said you know immediately afterwards
same sentence there wasn't like a 10
minute gap it was right there
that it could well be a placeholder uh
this isn't something that i even took
seriously what i was saying and
especially as someone who has worked in
retail
placeholders exist a price being in a
system uh
for a retailer is unlikely to be
accurate because
these companies are intentionally not
going to tell the retailers the actual
price
ahead of time because that is the number
one source of leaks so
sure there's someone i guess on this
reddit thread who said i find it odd
that 5.99 would be a placeholder amount
why not just use n
a why is it specifically placed at 5.99
and not any other number this is
something that i have seen routinely
um the fact that this blew up and made
news as much as it did was was really
absurd to me and i really didn't expect
it um sometimes the way those things
work in the system is someone just
guesses what they think a likely price
is just
one person who works in the system side
of that at some point puts a random
price and they're often
9.99 uh games can often be listed
i mean i worked in retail in australia
of course as 99 and they would end up
being 109. it can straight up just
be a guess retailers don't function
smoothly it's not like this grand plan
where everyone sticks to it where
they're like oh this is consistent and
we have the data it's all over the place
and it's a giant mess and everything's
on fire all the time for those companies
so it is not unlikely to me at all that
even the most professional of retailers
would just arbitrarily type in 5.99 i'm
also not going to tell you it's not 5.99
i don't know but to report on this as
though it's true
um and certainly to report on it as
though i said
it was true even though i have
absolutely no idea was just
wild to watch unfault [ __ ] review
tech
uh usa posted a video saying a lot of
pierce says the xbox series x
is expensive thankfully he updated the
headline but there are just a lot of
people lying
just saying a lot of stuff that's not
true so yeah i think it's uh of all of
these sources every single one of them
forbes is in here i get that that people
want to have their juicy headlines
saying this is the xbox series x-ray
you'll hate the most
uh this ultimately doesn't mean anything
um especially because if you look into
how retailers work at all i promise you
microsoft is not
telling those retailers what the cost of
this thing is
any minute before they can because
retailers
always leak things so it very much got
out of hand
there was some insane conspiracy
theories as well
people saying like oh microsoft paid her
to say this so that sony will come out
with the price
this is not how this industry works
playstation and xbox or sony and
microsoft aren't paying influences
to leak fake prices to get the other one
to announce their price i promise you
we are so below them we don't matter
these business decisions are made so far
in advance and yes it's very annoying to
have to wait and it's annoying that it
takes so long for them to actually
reveal the meat of the thing especially
when they're already putting pre-orders
up for something you don't know how
expensive it is
i'm also not saying that nobody should
talk about it you know i made the
comment i didn't
i didn't expect nobody to talk about it
but um
to report it like it was true was
frustrating which you know this is a lie
a lot of piss says xbox series x is 5.99
is not a thing i ever said i didn't say
that i just said someone else
who works in retail told me it was and
it could be a placeholder
but i guess like the forbes at least the
forbes one up here
that's like that i'm all right with that
headline anyway
i i think it is very unlikely that any
retailer has been told the price of
these consoles
um however i am going to show you
another leak this time i have actual
pictures
uh because i guess people are messaging
me more of this information now and it
is still for the xbox series x and it is
still
quite expensive so i'm going to show you
this next leak um
with that in mind i do think this one is
potentially a little bit more valid but
before anyone gets carried away with
their headlines alana pierce did not say
the xbox series x was this price if you
are reporting on it and you don't want
to report on it
inaccurately you would say oh lana
pierce had this leak to do her or not
mention me at all but i am not the one
saying this is the price you're not
allowed to source me
that's not how sources work so these are
photos that i have
of an actual
store not a not a screenshot this is
actually someone's system that they've
taken a photo of
a uk retailer obviously the person is
asked to remain anonymous
i did crop the photos a tiny bit so that
i felt like they were less identifiable
so this person couldn't potentially lose
their job
but basically this is number one
the first image here shows the xbox one
series x as being 4 99. to be even more
specific on that though it does say
499.99
which would make it an even 500 which i
don't know if if microsoft would do but
it is worth noting that the extra 99
is on the end there the xbox series x
controller black is being 59.99 the xbox
series x controller white xbox series x
controller blue
and then this one is a cod dummy sku
xbox series x
59.99 pretty detailed didn't know there
was a blue controller maybe that's news
that i missed somewhere but i didn't
know that that was a thing
again could completely be placeholder
prices it doesn't necessarily mean
anything
this is also from the uk meaning it is
pounds if this is
real um which again i have no idea why
microsoft would be telling retailers
this far ahead of time they know that's
how things get leaked
it happens every time walmart leaks
always happen before e3 it would be so
stupid
to give any retailer the information
well before they need it it just doesn't
make sense to do that
when i worked in retail i was at eb
games in australia for like five or six
years they didn't ever give us the price
of any games or hardware really until it
was officially revealed so i don't know
why this would be any different it would
just be the dumbest thing to do but
the reason this one seems a little bit
more credible than the last one which
was very very basic
is because they also have the
playstation listed
the playstation 5 digital and
playstation 5 are in the same
app the playstation 5 digital and the
playstation 5 are in the same system
uh listed as 0.01 pounds
so why would this one be 0.01
and the other one uh be 499.99 that is a
little bit more unusual
that's why i felt like maybe it was
worth mentioning making making a video
about obviously
obviously people really care i've
certainly learned that but i still do
want to disclose
i don't think this actually means
anything i don't think this is
necessarily true
but i guess i'm not going to keep this
information from you because i
don't necessarily think that it's true
because placeholder is going to
placehold it is up to you if you think
this is true or not
uh also worth going into the conversion
rate for pounds i think that that would
make the xbox one
series x about 600 us dollars let's let
me check that real quick
so 4.99 pounds is 660
us dollars um i don't know that they'd
ever release a console for
660. and i guess there is always going
to be
a differentiator between where it's from
it could be 650 if you were to convert
that but maybe i think it's probably
more likely that they'd go 599 or 600
instead
it is weird that it does technically
cost different values entirely
uh depending on which country you're in
but that's what it would be right now
so yeah just thought that i would share
obviously people are very interested
uh this means absolutely nothing to me
in my professional opinion i don't think
it makes any sense to run with this
doesn't mean i'm not going to show you
if if you feel differently but as
someone working in retail
you just don't get this information that
only while it is strange that the
playstation 1 has
listed uh the 0.01
um skus in there and
and now they have about the same amount
of detail they both say they have zero
in stock
it could just again very simply be
someone guess or someone's trolling me
like this could have been sent to me
with someone hoping that i would leak it
because i did the first one and they
just put that in arbitrarily in the
system themselves like
we have no proof that this means
anything is all i'm trying to say
i just think that you're not gonna know
the price until microsoft announces the
price you're not gonna know sony's price
until they announce the price
and while i'm sure they try to pay
attention to the competition i don't
think
there is any um dramatic sleuthing going
on where anyone's paying any influences
to say something costs something that it
doesn't it's just absurd
but there you have it it's up to you
make your own mind up all right that's
it for me today you guys i will see
y'all next time